It's so easy, you guys.
It's one rubber band,
four French hairpins,
and one fierce b**** later.
You're gonna walk away from
this class with three new styles
that you can do every
day on your own at home,
and we're going to give
you all of the tips,
all of the products,
the tools so you can
get the looks that you want.
I'm gonna show you
guys how to get
this natural polished wavy
look, fun festive braid look,
versatile ponytail, and then
turn it into this elegant bun.
It's really important
to know what
your hair type is so that you
know which products to use.
There's four different
types of hair.
There's straight, there's wavy,
there's curly, there's coily.
We're gonna give you
the perfect recipe
to get whatever look you
want for your hair type.
I literally live
by a heat protectant.
You can actually do
a whole look with this.
If you are getting a curly cut
and you see the stylist pulling
out razors, just run.
Well, now every
hairstylist is gonna hate me.